the influx of migrants moving toward the
southern border is being fueled by
dangerous conditions in Central America
that includes large groups of people
from Honduras El Salvador and Guatemala
ed O'Keefe reported on the conditions
those people face during a visit to
Guatemala City in June I remember you
documenting that ad good morning good
morning so let's talk about facts this
morning right walk us through the
process of asylum seekers seeking refuge
in this country so you you essentially
you know you come to the border you come
to a port of entry you essentially tell
that border official that you have some
stated fear in some reason why it is
that you want to seek asylum and
eventually there's supposed to be a
court hearing where this issue sort of
starts to break down is the backlog and
and the concern that the president says
that he has is that it's kind of an
open-ended issue you know you can you
can claim it because of race religion
nationality maybe something political
going on in your country and the issue
is that I think part of his frustration
is you can't necessarily go back and
prove that so people make these
open-ended requests and and as as he
said and as a federal official said
yesterday they essentially get to they
get a free ticket into the u.s. allowing
individuals to disappear into the
interior to live and work illegally as a
defining what is credible fear is seems
to be pretty big right right so you have
government officials saying the bar for
that is very low is it well you know it
depends on who you ask and certainly a
lot of the people who come have
legitimate reasons I remember when we
were in Guatemala when one couple we met
young couple had a son with them they
were fleeing Nicaragua and and the folks
in Guatemala said we're starting to see
more people come from Nicaragua because
of the problems that they're having now
with the Ortega administration and so
there you might have a legitimate
political reason to leave she said that
you know we are essentially part of the
opponents of the President and we had
reason to leave the country and they
were trying to decide do we go through
Mexico the United States or do we go see
our family in Canada it's clear we need
a better system there's no question
about that but when you go and talk to
these people some of the people I met in
in Texas they are desperate and they are
terrified right so to see them portrayed
as invaders I think is very tough to
hear for a lot of people know the
situations that these people are coming
from yeah and look they're being told
you know if you if you don't like your
situation
go make a run for it the woman I talked
to there in Guatemala her husband and
her 15 year old son had gone and with
the goal of getting to Houston and the
husband died in Mexico so she was
waiting for her 15 year old son at that
location to come back I said well why
did he go and why did he take one of
your children and she said well we were
told that if you take a kid with you you
have a better chance of getting in so go
on the street they're being told this
who's telling them where does that come
from well it comes from years of pattern
and practice
well now you're the president of United
States say if you throw rocks it could
be met with gunfire and bullets what do
you make of that well look there have
been issues in the past where Border
Patrol agents have had to fire across in
New Mexico to see the military do that
would be something else entirely and I
think the Mexicans would have a great
deal of concern we have high-ranking
military officials though questioning
whether 15,000 troops should be sent to
the border but to Edie thank you and
everyone should go follow what you
documented in Guatemala it was really
eye-opening thank you